this award show was really kind of a
train wreck there was a check who was uh
co-hosting it and they said that she
tested positive for the rhona so let's
uh take a look last night
i know all of you i know this black guy
is who's hosting it it's supposed to be
country music no offense i mean you all
have hip hop and basketball you know
what i mean
it's like
just fly with your flock bro
i'm not against you but you're up here
like the melanated people invented
country
at the music
we was making country music in what kind
of before johnny cash and merle haggard
stole the black man's country music
it's like all right bro it's so angry
he's not even angry his [ __ ] is
not even angry he's so angry he's just
doing his job so this is not like shut
the [ __ ] up yeah and yeah i think he had
to apologize to some [ __ ] don't
apologize don't know you seen this
before yeah i've seen this i've never
seen this i've seen this
there were so many black people there
sorry to say but like so many black
celebrities who have nothing to do
with country music and it's like
why no disrespect
to uh
to the the funky brothers of music i
love earth wind and fire run dmc etc but
i mean like country music is different
country music's different it's not
wakanda hi patrick halley uh
this is called reparation
we had miley cyrus for a couple of
months
you get us too all right there you go
trade-off
let's keep it a stack
it's pretty common for award shows to
invite celebrities and people who have
nothing to [ __ ] do with the genre
since forever
forever i i'm used to seeing misplaced
celebrity i stopped watching award shows
a long time ago as a result he's cringy
it's basically like who's the biggest
name we can get and whether you like it
or not you know
having certain people attracts more
[ __ ] trying to get people to watch
yeah that's just what it is you don't
have to love it why are you coming at
black folks like they're the ones who
made the hiring decision it's like it's
not black folks it's one dude
it's it's one dude
they ain't got no country music in
wakanda wakanda is not a real place
dum-dum
i don't think he knows that he knows
that he knows that he just wants to be
as flagrant as possible with it which
hey you know that's wild
that's just stupid whatever
we never said nothing about that
and then his [ __ ] all angry
he's not even angry he's just doing his
job yeah there's a whole generation of
people who didn't know country music
existed until your [ __ ] video so now
there's a bunch of black people like
what's country music let me go let me go
take a look
and i hope they become the next country
stars just to piss you off i want you to
be an old man and just see a bunch of
[ __ ] and grills on [ __ ] tractors
being like
oh my pimped out tractor i want i hope
that happens there's some white people
with girls doing country right now
really yeah
which is why i'm going to be hosting the
next country awards yes and i'm very
excited i agree i'll be like hey guys
i'm very happy to be your host this is
adam from wakanda here to infiltrate and
take over country spaces melanated and
it's not going to be safe from anywhere
from me that's right so what what do you
know about country in regards i know a
couple of things about country i got a
country friend i got a cowboy friend as
a matter of fact i had to go to his
wedding cowboy boots and all
rifles okay
where alberta okay yeah
that marriage didn't last long but
that's a different story
um turns out to find another track
tracker to write no comments um
yeah so
it listen it was it was what it was and
okay okay i i know a couple yeah i know
a couple of things about country i had
to leave the country with that okay
whiskey
i have
dated uh a woman before and i remember
we were talking about music and she said
her first favorite music is country
uh how's it going
and uh first song she played for me
we can go fast or we can go slower come
on take a ride on my big green tractor
everybody's accurate i'm like this is
this has got to be a metaphor for a
stick it's like no no it's really a
tractor
but we can go fast or we can go slower
i mean just because they're white don't
mean they don't know about metaphors no
no i think they know about metaphors but
they really be talking about the
attractors a lot we can go fast or we
can go slower no it might be a metaphor
that might be a metaphor i'm pretty sure
these [ __ ] were getting spicy
yeah they weren't against yeah they were
getting spicy it's like horse
[ __ ] or horses horse
horses horse horse horse not your [ __ ]
your horse okay i don't know
that's not country
my country [ __ ]
horse tractor okay song by jason aldean
i'm not crazy that really is a song and
i can take you for a ride on my big
green tractor we can go slower make it
go faster down through the woods and out
to the pasture
long as i'm with you it really don't
matter climb up on my lap and drive if
you want to
girl you know you got me to hold on to
we can go to town but maybe if you'd
rather i'll take you for a ride on my
big green track okay let me tell you
something
it might be a metaphor but you have to
understand
the tractor can't be black
it's got to be green
it can't be white because nobody has it
and they you damn well know they have a
john deere so it got to be green
but it could be a metaphor for a dick
come on and ride on my big black tractor
that's porn now that's four that's not
even a metaphor that's just warm it
can't be it has to be green because you
know it's john deere
hey man that's mad i'm not gonna lie
you really can't see it on my lap it
really don't matter as long we together
oh my big black tractor
do you know what my favorite country
song is what country boy
oh yeah yeah that's fine you ever heard
country boy no at the end they got one
of the most iconic portions of country
music i've ever heard
this is probably the most american
patriotic thing i ever heard it was so
amazing it made me want to fight for the
second amendment and i live in canada
aaron lewis okay 170 million views
hey
ah that's mars makes you want to i love
my guns i love my wife i love my family
and i love this land
and this should be all over her
attitudes
because this is america and the country
bar is good enough for me you see me
you turned blood so quick
oh jason got my shotgun
i can't do a great southern accent but
hey i love my guns you feel me i am mad
at you me you know i'm a drinker go
ahead this is my song
whoa let's go can you be looking at your
liquor bottle like that hey
yeah yeah cause i know you were a
drinker that's like that [ __ ] right
there wait till you hit the chorus
[Music]
yo the door open
the door
and then only women's legs that's
opening up yeah
what was this guy's name michael noley
mr cannoli i don't know who he is
[ __ ] you
uh outside of that
yeah this man was just mad for no reason
patrick patrick howley my bad chris
stapleton tennessee whiskey that's that
[ __ ] right there get the [ __ ] out of
here
so that's what i have to say about this
video but let us know what you guys
think in the comments
below that's my [ __ ] they didn't even
know what we knew about a little bit
about country i don't know
no you don't know you all know [ __ ]
about [ __ ] no